So now we really want to use the full power of our rewrite rules
to help us complete the parsing chart.
We've already seen 2 possible ways to do it.
If the dot is right before a nonterminal,
then we take the closure or predict what's going to happen,
by bringing in and rewriting rules that start with a (c).
If, on the other hand, the dot is right before a terminal,
a token--a fixed part of the input--
we shift over it.
We just move our finger to the right, assuming that this new token, (c),
is exactly what we see in the input.
But there is a third case--a "corner" case:
3 corners--that's hard to draw;
actually, that's not hard to draw; something with 3 corners is a triangle--
in which there's nothing after the dot.
What if there's no (c) and there's no (d), and we've reached the end?
We've done a lot of shifting and our finger is already
as far to the right as it can go.
Well, now we're going to reduce--
by applying the rule: (x --> a b)
in reverse.
For example, let's say that the input was: <a b blah>
and we were right here--we'd seen these 2 characters--
and one of the rules in our grammar was:
(x --> a b).
I match up this (a) with this one, this (a) with this one--
and I'm going to take my input and conceptually change it,
removing the (a b) and replacing them with (x)
as if I'm constructing the parse tree
or applying the rewrite rules in reverse.
We've seen before how one direction
corresponds to string generation,
and one direction corresponds to parsing.
So once we've matched our predictions exactly,
the input has corresponded to (a)
and the input has corresponded to (b)
and we have rewrite rule: (x --> a b),
we're going to apply that rewrite rule in reverse
to do parsing--removing (a) and (b) from the input--conceptually--
and replacing them with (x).
This is called reduction.